it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts to Star
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen right there go ahead and do it or
visit cdsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail
bass joins us right now and she always
has the goods so what's good uh what's
good is this these are this is the siren
you can hear the siren song of your
favorite music while swimming these are
waterproof not water resistant
waterproof so while you're swimming some
people swim for therapeutic reasons some
people swim for their exercise because
you know swimmers they have the least
amount of body fat that's how you get to
look like Michael Phelps by swimming you
put these on and you get up to 10 hours
of sound see there you can see in the
video somebody is underwater with these
these are designed to do that this is
from underwater audio what's really cool
is all you do is you hook them onto your
goggles you have a little cord in the
back that you see right there and just
three controls so you can fast forward
through songs that you want to skip
press play press pause you don't have to
go in the water you know when you go in
the water and there's a speaker on
saying
you don't have that you have the whole
song that's so true and I mean you could
put up to 2 000 songs on trading in the
water is big oh yeah absolutely that you
have and also rehabbing is huge yes now
you can rehab and not have to worry
about being distracted just focus on oh
music and get the work done absolutely
and we have these for 59.99 so go to
cbsdeals.com right now because it's pool
season okay what do we have here I love
the jump smart this is one of our good
ones that sell out people love this and
true story my boyfriend's twins they
just turned 16 handed them over the keys
of the car and the car wouldn't start
and he was doubtful he's like that's not
gonna work this works up to a V8 this is
not something with this it's a jump
starter let me show you how easy it is
to connect because the girls started it
he's a girl dad he's like you got to do
it yourself so I'm going to show you
just put that in right there boom and
you're ready and it and it has and it
has protection so you're not going to do
it the wrong way it has safety features
built in but not all only can you put
that I'm just going to leave that in
here I want I want people to focus on
this is like 10 and 1 because it has a
compass it has a temperature gauge it
has two usb chargers and a USBC because
when you have no battery in your phone
in your car the car is dead and you
still need to use your phone to call
somebody you're going to have to charge
that phone so this has a charger the
flashlight an alarm all in one house
this one we have for
104.99deals.com for that one people like
that one it's a great gift for kids just
getting a new car this is this is just
in time for Father's Day you're a man
who likes to groom you look like a look
look at them
this is from black wolf not only does it
have a body scrubber look at this this
is a beautiful toiletry bag use that
instead of a loofah because the loofah's
got it yeah yeah it's nice I use the
face scrub wonderful these are wonderful
upscale toiletries for the man in your
life to have the things that they need
to you know take care of themselves how
much is that this we have for 49.99 also
apparently Gail realized that we have
Chargers on the show this is the rush
charge comment this is my Essential
charger I can carry this small little
thing in my purse and it charges
multiple devices in a can at the same
time a phone a tablet it could do a
YouTube video game remote video game
yeah the controller you could do three
at once it could do most phone types
that you can charge this is really great
because it has pass-through technology
so even if you leave this in your phone
and plug your phone into the wall at
night and you plug this into the wall it
is still charged it charges and then you
can take them both with you but I like
that it's almost 100 yeah take it with
you and look at that size you can fit in
your pocket and my purse is like this
big I know strange for a woman but it's
this big and it's and it's and and it's
and it's just tiny and I love that you
can get this for
39.99 this is a great deal it's a great
one to go with you are you shopping now
no I'm just not
I appreciate you well done once again
all right of course we partnered with
all these companies to get these deals
to buy anything that you saw scan the QR
code on your screen right now or head
over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now we
will be right back okay